very organizer please take a seat
welcome to the second talk this
afternoon julik she's a PhD students
back at home and she's going to talk
about so this last talk and I want to
present to you a tool in quantum
cryptography authentication of quantum
states this tool in itself is also an
application maybe you want a quantum
state that can be a goal in itself but
my goal today is to convince you or to
inspire you to see this cryptographic
primitive also as a tool to build other
things and I'm gonna show you sort of
some examples or some some samplings on
how you might go about doing that just
informally to get an introduction what's
what is what our quantum authentication
codes what does it mean to authenticate
state well the goal of a quantum
authentication code is to prevent
information from being altered while
it's being sent or stored somewhere like
this you start with some quantum states
I then there is some kind of encoding
procedure this is a quantum Channel but
it depends on a classical key K then
it's being for example send over some
quantum Channel and there is maybe
somebody sitting in the middle that is
attacking this it's doing some arbitrary
thing with the state and whoever is on
the other side and it's receiving this
state does some kind of decoding
procedure that depends on the same key
either he when he gets out the original
quantum state or he will notice that
something has happened to the state and
he will output some kind of special
reject state so this reject state
asserts it's outside of our space of
possible messages
but you can also use this if you want to
like I describe it as a sort of sender
receiver setting but you can also think
of this as maybe you want to store your
information somewhere on the cloud and
the lid then later retrieve it so then
you would be the one doing both the
encoding and the decoding if you're
coming from a more classical crypto
perspective then you might have seen
these two things being called a signing
algorithm the checking algorithm I
purposefully don't use these names in
the quantum setting and just mention
some things too to put some boundaries
in the context this key K it's a
one-time use so you can use it once to
send a message encoded and decoded and
then if you want to send another message
and one important thing to note is that
it's so if this decoding rejects then
your information is also gone and this
really differentiates an authentication
code from an error correcting code with
an error correcting code you want to
increase the probability that we can
always retrieve our information back but
we're also up against a slightly simpler
attacker easier attacker namely usually
some probabilistic noise that it's
presumed to be somewhat small here we're
up against an arbitrary malicious
attacker that will try to do the worst
possible thing to our state so we cannot
guarantee that we always get it back but
we hope to guarantee you that we either
get it back or we notice that something
okay so we just saw authentication of a
state it prevents that state from being
altered at all but there is a related
task that we might want to do that might
seem not related at the beginning we
already saw a lot of this today the
verification of a computation
essentially verifying the commutation is
preventing the input from being altered
except in the very ones very specific
way namely the computation that we want
to do that we want to perform or if you
look at it from the other side you can
see verification or you can see the
authentication of a state as verifying
the identity so I give my input state my
encoded input States to some server and
at the end I verified that they actually
performed the identity on my state so if
you don't remember anything else from
this talk I want you to remember this
kind of connection that even though they
seem quite different at first sight
they're actually very similar and I want
to convince you today that we can use
these quantum authentication codes or a
cue ACS as an ingredient for
cryptographic verification protocols so
that will be also at the outline for
today the first part which will be a
little bit more than than one half of
the talk I will give you a more formal
definition of quantum authentication I
will give you two examples of different
codes to make things a bit a little bit
more concrete and I'll discuss a little
bit its relation to encryption and some
other definitions and then in the second
part I will touch upon some applications
and do specific scenarios one which we
have seen a lot of today already
client-server verifier prover this kind
of setting the delegated computation and
another setting relates to some recent
work on multi-party computation
all right so let's get started with
formalities authentication codes this
study was initiated in 2000 2002 already
and the definition consists of two parts
the first part is pretty simple
straightforward correctness it
essentially says that if nothing happens
then the decryption should always accept
so the attacker doesn't do anything so
we just concatenate the Anker encoding
and decoding procedures then we should
have identity and original messages
that's not really the interesting part
the interesting part is the security I'm
going to show you a big formula don't
worry we're going to digest it a bit so
the security definition that was given
by Barnum and others in 2002 intuitively
what it says is if the decryption
accepts then we have to have to have to
guarantee that the recovered message is
close to the original message this
intuition and now the formalization is
this formula below but let's digest it a
bit so here on the Left ignore the
quantifiers for now but on the left
I wrote the real scenario so what
happens in the actual case so we start
with some input state row we encode it
then there is some kind of attack map in
the middle that we don't know anything
about we decode it and we look at
whatever state comes out and because the
attacker doesn't know the key so sort of
his attack is independent of the key K
and the and he does he doesn't have any
information of this key K we take the
average over all keys in that state and
that's what we say is like the actual
state and then we want this states to be
closed in some sense to some ideal state
and this is a sort of paradigm that we
use a lot in cryptography both classical
and quantum where we say okay this is
what actually happens where they're
actually actual algorithms and our keys
and the actual attacks but it should
always be captured by some ideal thing
where we really limit what the adversary
can do in this case the ideal scenario
or the ideal outcome state it's just we
get the only freedom we give the
adversary is to choose some real number
a some probability and
rather than see a he lets the original
state through so ro comes out and with
probability 1 minus a he sabotages and
the reject state comes out so what this
ideal functionality captures is saying
ok the only freedom that we give to our
adversary is choosing whether or not to
let the state through essentially we can
never prevent the adversary from
sabotaging the wire and like throwing
everything out but then it will always
result in a reject and this
approximation sign in the middle it
really just means that these two states
should be or the difference between
these two states should be closed in
Trey's norm to some factor that's
negligible in some parameters that sit
in inside
any questions about this definition
are you really interested in weak states
or do you really care only about pure
states well in this case I want to write
it as a mixed state because it's really
sort of a probabilistic make sure and
and it's like it can be a classical
mixture over these two things like the
adversary can choose to flip a coin and
like sort of either do this but you see
here that I also wrote that this is a
first attempt so I think it's a little
odd because the rejection is a pure
state but the yeah the origin originally
input can be kind of anything and it can
also be entangled with something but
usually what this decoding protocol
would do is like it detects some kind of
error and then it just traces out the
original message and replaces it with
some fixed sate and that can be a pure
state
so wouldn't it be satisfactory to open a
single bit zero one and then have the
rest of the state be any arbitrary thing
yes you can also you can also do it in
this kind of protocol so to have a
separate register where you have a kind
of flag that says accept or reject
that's also perfectly fine but then in
the reject case you have to specify what
state is in this reject state and that's
really because we're working with this I
a real ideal scenario then it becomes
the question like in the ideal scenario
if we reject what should be in this in
this other state so this this really
captures a lot of the intuition of what
we want from authentication and during
the rest of the talk you can also kind
of think of the authentication like this
it will be perfectly fine so you see
there is also an objection state up
there in the quantifiers right well the
rejection state states just some fixed
states you can just think of this is for
example 0 like the all 0 string or
something and just some state that's not
allowed to be used as a message and
these these quantifiers just says that
for every attack so anything the
adversary can do we can always kind of
simulate it by having the adversary just
choose only this this parameter a such
that these two things are the same
there's we don't parameterize over this
rejects oh yeah thank you
yeah this are the the encoding and
decoding procedures are quantum maps but
the key is always classical but okay so
this is a this is all nice and fine but
somehow I don't really capture
everything that we can do in the quantum
case so let me show you one example so
suppose that we start with some state
I'm going to write just a pure state now
just to make things a little bit shorter
so we start with some stage sigh we
encode it at some point we will decode
it again the attack in the middle will
be the following thing so the adversary
just prepares in his own memory some
extra qubit so they will start in a
state 0 apply a huh tomorrow so it's now
in the state plus and then conditioned
on this wire he will perform some kind
of attack on this state now this may be
multiple qubits let's say if this was a
single qubit then the encoding this was
a single qubit maybe the encoding
consisted of M different qubits right
the encoding map might blow it up into
multiple states and he will just apply
some outrageous attack like flip
everything that will first for sure be
detected by our decoding but he only
does it conditioned on this wire here so
you can ask okay so what do we get out
at the end well what we get out is
quite easily compute what we get out we
got zero times the original state
because this is zero then nothing
happens and we only accept this first
wire was one we will get the reject
state here so here we really have a kind
of situation where at the end we have
some kind of entanglement or some
superposition between acceptance and
rejections and we don't see this of
course in the classical world and it's
kind of also not really captured by this
definition I tried to think of an
example of some encoding decoding that
would satisfy that definition but didn't
do what we want I couldn't really think
of one but still I hope you agree with
me that kind of not everything that can
happen in the world is captured by this
definition so if you trace out the zero
then you get yeah so if you trace out
the zero then you still get this thing
so this really this example really
satisfies this definition still so it's
not really an example of why this
definition is wrong it's just that if
you look at this as the thing that
happens in the ideal world it's not
really what happens right because this
seems to suggest that we always throw
out all the all the entangled wires
whereas we actually keep some of the
entanglement and maybe we will measure
his wire afterwards and
yes exactly so if we if we just look at
this state here that comes out then we
will have well what with probability 1/2
we will have the original state and so
it still satisfies the definition but
somehow what happens here is not really
captured there so I'm just gonna so at
the end of the decoding process are you
saying that I have this state which you
can either be the original state or
project and I don't know what it is what
happens in the world the adversary can
make it one of the two and that
classically you know doesn't happen yeah
although you cannot really really he
cannot really make it one of the two but
at least he can he cannot decide what
will happen but he can fix what will
happen kind of so but it's a problem
with composition or something if this
was used many times yes maybe something
like this I couldn't think of a simple
example maybe we can think about it
anyway um just to continue so sort of a
more general definition that will anyway
capture all of these things was given
one decade later by de premios and so if
I where the core if the definition is
really the same so if you just want to
think about this one that's fine but
here we add this side information wire
so whatever information the adversary
still has so the only difference is now
that our input state row is both on a
message register and a site information
register so it's a joint state our
encoding and decoding still really only
happens on the message register such as
identity of the site information but the
attack so whatever happens here in the
middle can happen on both and then what
we say is instead of requiring that
there is some kind of probability a that
chooses one or the other
there should be two quantum Maps the Phi
except math and if I reject map that act
only on the side information register so
that our real case here on the top is
approximately equal to the to the ideal
case where in the ideal case either
nothing happens to the message and the
except map is applied to the site
information or the message is rejected
and then the reject map if we look again
at this this picture here then the
accept map
that map would just be identity like
this would this zero would be the site
information and this would be the
message register and the reject map is
just a bit flip starting state role
would be the tensor product anyway this
situation is still captured by this this
is just really a more general version of
this one which captures the quantum
effects a little bit more nicely yes
you're right sorry yeah this should be a
tensor product thank you
okay now we've seen all these like long
formulas let's just go to some examples
to make it a little bit more
lighthearted the first example is a
Clifford code maybe a quick show of
hands who would like to see a definition
or we go that's great
so you may be familiar with the
polygroup
the n-cubed polygroup we've seen it also
already in some previous talks it's
really just another product of
raising XC but you can also think why
here
so the n-cubed polygroup is just a
tensor product of n Poly's and can be
any combination identity bit flip face
flip or both and the Clifford group on n
qubits
is defined in terms of this polygroup so
it's really the set of unit ares on and
qubits such that for all Polly's in the
n cubed polygroup
the conjugation of that poly with this
with is you is still in the polygroup
and then I'm gonna make a few minor
changes because I kind of I don't want
to worry about face in this case so it
can be either in the polygroup or in
like - that thing and I'm going to take
the cushions over norm 1 so the Clifford
group it's kind of it yeah so it's kind
of all the things that's map Polly's to
other Polly's by conjugating them and
one really cool property to mention
about this Clifford group is that if we
take any Polly element that's not
identity and we conjugated with a random
Clifford element then we get a random
non-identity Polly
so this has kind of a sort of rent
randomizing effect on the quali croup as
well and that will be important later on
reiterated at that point
so anyway Clifford group it's just a
group of unit Ares
it doesn't do all quantum computation it
doesn't even do classical computation
but it's still a pretty big group of
perfect code our key is going to be a
random element from the Clifford group
on n plus 1 elements and it's just some
parameter here security will depend on N
and to encode a state psi what we will
do is we will append a number of zeros
to the state all these states use weak
traps and then we just apply this random
Clifford to it and that's it that's all
this is like our authentication of this
tape side and then to decode we just do
the inverse so we apply the transpose of
C our key and we measure whether all of
we measure all these trapped positions
in the computational basis and if
they're still all 0 we'll say it's fine
and if they're not all 0 anymore then we
will say well something went wrong and
we reject n squared or some it's big but
it's not
and one can show that the Clifford code
is a secure quantum authentication code
the probe is actually really short
so I will just show that the Clifford
Code is secure if the attack is a poly
attack and we've just seen a normal
attack that we can generalize this to
general unitary attacks using this poly
twirl you don't really have to worry
about that I'm just going to do a sort
of special case because they're already
kind of captures so let's say that we
have some attack map is some poly I'm
just writing this and to keep things
interesting we're going to assume that
this poly is not the identity because
otherwise boring so we want to look at
the real state which was the expectation
over the key in this case the keys are
clifford of the decoding
Tech map encoding right-to-left applied
to some input state I'm gonna use a pure
state here just because it's shorter
notation and we hope that this is equal
to so let me first write out what the
state looks like in the right before we
perform the measurement of the decoding
encoding ended with measuring the trap
so I'm just gonna write the free
measurement state that looked like okay
so first we encode the state so that's
applying our Clifford to sight ends or
some zeros then the attack happens well
we just assumed that this wizard poly
and then we decode it by first applying
the inverse of a Clifford and but
remember that we took a random Clifford
and I just mentioned earlier when I was
defining the Clifford group that if we
take any poly it's not the identity and
we conjugated with a random Clifford
then what we get out is a random poly so
this state is actually equal to taking a
random poly let me call it P prime just
to distinguish and apply this P prime to
side 1000 State now measure this state
we have here if we measure this what is
the probability that we're going to get
the all zeroes outcome here we measure
it in the conversation
no any takers hint it's on the board
okay so this is the program that you if
you apply a random non-identity poly
here the probability that you'll get the
all-0 measurement here is going to be
identity on all of these positions and
then maybe so that means so this is our
sort of pretty measurement state and our
post measurement state so what's written
up here well with overwhelming
probability it's going to be equal to so
if we if we took our original definition
with this just this parameter a then a
would be equal to almost equal to zero
so that's the majority of the clifford
code fairly simple procedure and how it
works but it's also a very powerful code
it's a second example of a code is the
trap code this one was just a little bit
later in the context of quantum one-time
programs the definition sounds a little
bit scarier but I promise nothing really
weird is happening here so instead of
taking a random Clifford as a cable
we'll take two elements namely a random
poly so this is sort of simpler thing
and a random permutation and both the
following the permutation are going to
work on three and then the encoding is
this whole thing so I always like to
draw this in a picture sorry this is the
error correcting code that takes a
single qubit 2n cubed but let's draw
this in a picture what's going on here
so the encoding works as follows you
start with your single say PSI you
append a number of pluses this is plus
2n and a number of zeros which are
sufficient for this zero to the end and
some extras for your error correcting
code so the first thing you do is you
apply an error correcting code which
essentially spreads out your data from
one qubit to multiple qubits that
already protects it a little bit right
that is not a new single location
anymore within locations the next thing
you do is you apply this random
permutation so everything is jumbled up
and finally you apply a random poly
which is one to one time pad so that
really hides with which qubits which
you're now given if you now give me this
state and I don't know what PI or P is
then I have no clue whether this is a
data qubit trap qubit
so we have our red cubits here which are
sort of spread out the data that needs
to be protected we have the zero traps
which will detect whether an attack has
happened in the computational basis and
we have less traps which will detect
whether an attack has happened in the
Pottermore basis and the decoding is
really similar to that in the Clifford
code so we essentially just undo
everything and measure whether the zeros
are still zeros whether the clusters are
still plusses and whether the error
correcting code also didn't detect any
errors we can also show that the trap
code is a secure point education proof
will be quite similar but I'm not gonna
do it now like what's done in front of a
distribution where ECC is a CSS code
right yes yeah we also have these kind
of zeroes and pluses to protect the two
different bases be probably the
underlying ideas are this so the trap
code is also secure its security depends
on the distance of the use of the air
correcting code that we use but we can
use for example air control with
distance square root of M and then we
would still get something negligible
so the aircraft encode is really you see
picture quickly again here to make sure
that if you want to attack like if you
want to alter up sigh you need to alter
a sufficient number of locations in this
random permutation so it's not like if
you wouldn't use this error correcting
code then you would have a single qubit
in here that would be read so
representing the data and then you could
potentially alter the state by guessing
its location so you would have in your
attack and this air cracking code just
make sure that that's harder because you
have to attack more locations yes ok now
I show you two codes they look pretty
similar but which one is better
well there's no real answer to this it
just kind of really depends so the
clifford code it has a really clean and
simple definition and the analysis go
through nicely and it's pretty strong
security on the other hand the trap code
has some more structure to it so we will
see this in the second part of my talk
that this structure allows you to
perform computations on the encrypted
data more easily in some sense and also
the encoding and decoding procedures
these maps they require in some sense
less quantum so the encoder doesn't have
to apply a full Clifford operation but
they just have to swap some wires and
apply Pauli's which arguably would be
simpler to do yeah the code might be but
I think there's some codes that do have
the right properties that seems s codes
I think they're like you started with
some zeroes and pluses and do some so
that could be relative but yeah it
really depends on what what you think
how do you get the circuit it's possible
to just I think it's just possible to
efficiently send for a Clifford circuit
box to it well there's more than these
two codes of course that I should that I
showed you there's a polynomial code
which is already the oldest there is a
more recent one which really nicely
captures the idea that we have to
authenticate to bases so it classically
authenticated it uses a classical
authentication on the computational
basis and it performs a Fourier
transform and then it does the same
thing again so on the other basis well
so it really depends on sort of what
you're doing which code there's a whole
landscape of different definitions out
there so I've shown you this like
original attempt to the definition and
it slightly sort of fix of that
definition but there's more definitions
for example there's a stronger a
definition that is concerned with key
recycling so that asks the question like
if everything is fine and the decoder
accepts that can we then reuse the key
for another round and we know that the
clifford code has this property the trap
code does not
another stronger variant that this sort
of on another axis then this key
recycling is the idea of ciphertext
authentication so what we've seen so far
is only plaintext authentication we
wants to protect this underlying state
psi but you might also say I want to
guarantee that nothing happened even to
my to my ciphertext and this is somehow
I think it's it's closer to the
classical definitions of authentication
that we have and in this work it was
used to define like some stronger notion
of encryption and one last thing that I
want to mention in this first part of
the talk which to me was very surprising
at first because this is really not true
in the classic world is that if encode
it is necessarily also an encryption
code will not give you a formal proof
but I can give you some intuition so in
quantum mechanics we have this idea that
if you measure in one basis if you get
information in one basis by measuring
then you necessarily disturb the other
basis you turn this around like
interpose this statement then you see if
you want to make sure that the other
basis cannot be disturbed then you must
make sure that in this first base is no
information can be given away so in
other words if we want to authenticate
one basis then we necessarily have to
encrypt the other basis want to
authenticate both bases that also means
we need to authenticate both faces this
is really a phenomenon that's uniquely
quantum there's also the reason why I've
been using like encoding decoding or
sometimes encrypting decrypting be
perceived commit to go both ways
so any quantum authentication scheme
gives a qkd scheme any qk DS scheme is a
koala authentication scheme so I don't
think any authentication scheme because
there's a qkd scheme it's not the key
distribution scheme but it's like it
also hides the information of the
underlying
encryptions but but if he calls it and
gives back the original state so that
distributes keys since all you have to
do is distribute an EPR care yeah I
guess you could use it to construct a QP
D scheme whether it then goes the other
way around I really don't know because
if you detect the eavesdropper then it's
your reject state and it's kind of maybe
it's kind of like in digital signature
schemes you can show that a one-way
function always gives a DSS and
vice-versa yeah there might be something
there I I wouldn't be able to
so just to answer and this like first
part of the talk with some open problems
because maybe you would like to also
work a little bit on this and I have a
small list of open problems it's by no
means exhaustive and there are some
references that I put after every point
they are not necessarily the paper that
posed this question or the paper that
then so answering this question is just
the point where I would suggest you
start reading up if you are interested
in so I briefly mentioned this this key
recycling and in the GYC paper they give
the definition of key recycling which
states that if the codes accepts then
the key should be used to get be able to
used again be used again but you can
also ask a question like if the decoding
rejects how much of the key is actually
compromised can we reuse it entirely can
we reuse part of it maybe this is really
nothing is known about this you can
generalize this question also a little
bit like can we design new codes that
maybe require or allow us to reuse the
key many times and you almost get into
the realm of digital signatures
another question is how to deal with
noise so the the codes that I showed you
today are really strict right if we
detect just a single error on our traps
we immediately reject and throw out
everything that we have and maybe that's
a little bit too strict and of course
you can salvage this by throwing an
error correcting code on top of
everything but that also feels like
you're doing double work so maybe can we
kind of combine the two and give some
threshold above which we reject but
below with which we say and one that I
personally find very interesting is sort
of what are the minimal capabilities
that we require from our encoding
encoder or decoder and we may be through
some interactive means have a classical
client outsource the encoding this
really relates a lot to it or Mila
talked about earlier this afternoon
where we asked approver to say prove
that they have a certain quantum state I
wonder whether it would be possible to
make approve or prepare an
authentication without them knowing the
key we have some ideas on this already
but doesn't quite work yet
yes sir you can imagine a scenario where
maybe the client wants to create an
encoding of a specific known state like
the zero State
I can maybe better comment on this at
some point after after the second part
because then we would can see there's
probably many more nice questions but
these are just so interesting so any
questions about this first two patient
codes the Clifford code code not then
let's move on to some applications we
already saw a lot of verifiable
computation here some of the things that
we already saw earlier today are sort of
further in terms of timeline than what
I'm going to present to you here so some
of the things that they achieve might be
actually better than what I will present
here but still I hope to convince you
that
the first scenario is just a client and
server or you can think about it as a
verifier improver the client has some
input so what's an input and want to do
some quantum computation on it and the
the prover is going to help the client
in doing this but they are not like they
they're not trustworthy so the client
would like to verify that the proof that
the server supposed to do so the picture
is really similar to what we had in the
beginning we start with some inputs API
which is encoded then given to our
untrustworthy prove err that's hopefully
going to computation then we decode the
state again and either we'd get the
result of our computation here so this C
is now another clipper but just some
pointers or we're going to reject this
is the my client-server crucially of
course the server doesn't know the key
otherwise good things with very simple
and if you look very closely you might
see that the client doesn't necessarily
decode with the same key so as part of
this part of the computation the client
may update their key so the update will
depend on the original key and whatever
the computation was supposed to be but
this will all be sort of classical
computation usually
and I think the the kind of most
standard or basic protocol was proposed
but in 2013 as part of some bigger
protocol for one-time programs as and
this protocol is using the trap code and
we'll evaluate this circuit see gate by
gate some gates will be simple and some
gates will require some extra
ingredients states the idea for the
simpler gates is to use transversal gate
applications you may know from for
example error correcting codes that if
he wants to apply a gate for example a
bit flip gate on the logical underlying
data what you can do is just apply a bit
flip on every single physical qubit and
that will result in applying a logical
bit that idea is what we're going to use
here as well so we're thinking in this
trap codes scenario so we have our data
which is kind of spread out using our
correcting code we have our zero traps
for the bit flips and our plus traps for
the face flips they're all nicely
permuted and with one and what we would
like to do is the following
right we would like to transfer Slee
apply for example a bit flip on our data
so we would like to have the server
apply an X exactly on all these
positions but the server doesn't know
the permutation so he cannot do this so
what we can do is the following we can
just apply an X everywhere the server
can certainly do this just apply an X on
every wire and the first thing we can
observe here that this is actually the
same thing as if he would have applied
an X only on the data and the zero trap
positions because a bit flip operation
on a + trap doesn't do anything
I'm gonna take these two things a little
bit apart this is the operation that we
actually wanted a server to do bit flips
on all the data qubits but he did a few
too many he also put fit flips on all
the zero traps but the client can fix
this classically on herself so she has
as part of the key a one-time pad which
is a Polly which consists of X's so she
can just update her key to kind of undo
these unwanted X's so she will add like
extra X inverses to her key as well and
then with the help of the client Valka
the client essentially did most of the
work here because they're going to with
the help of the client the server
without knowing the key has applied
access exactly through decisions if
you're very sharp you may notice by okay
then the client might as well like the
server might as well have just done
nothing and the client could have just
updated the key on the data positions
that's perfectly true usually say to do
but I think this is sort of a nice way
to expose the general idea without
getting in too many so that's the
underlying idea of many gates and this
this idea of transversal computation
works for it well the simple the Polly
gates that so the X of is he also works
for the same out and surprisingly it
even works for computational basis
measurement so the server if they want
to do a logical based measurement can
just measure all the qubits give the
list of classical measurement results to
decline and the client from this list of
results can compute the underlying
measurement results
this is assuming you're reducing the
stabilizer code right yes so it does put
some requirements on the error
correcting code that you're using that's
correct okay so this is pretty nice but
not really all the gates that we want to
be able to do so the other gays they
need a little bit of a different trick
and the trick is using magic states
outside of the scope of the education of
verification what a magic state does or
a magic state computation does it
affords posted we have our input States
I we want to apply the following gate on
it so this is just the base gate which
wrote like a square root of C we want to
apply this gate subside but we don't
actually have the like components in our
service to widest gate if we have access
to this state which we'll call the magic
state so this is like the phase gate
applied to plus and we just perform this
circuit here which you can work out for
yourself on a piece of paper if you're
interested but suppose that we could do
this entire circuit here so it consists
of C naught some measurement and some
classically controlled Poly's then what
comes out at the bottom is exactly our
phase gate applied to original inputs
this is known as magic
but the crucial thing for us here is
that this circuit here in the middle
only consists of operations that we
already kind of know how to do so if we
have an encoding of our inputs API and
we somehow managed to get hold of an
encoding of this magic state here then
we could do this entire circuit under
our trap code so honoring and
authenticated data and we would get out
and encoding of the resulting state of
course this does require us to somehow
get hold of these leg magic states and
this is where your question from earlier
comes in so what if we can have a
classical client that can somehow force
approver or a server to prepare an
authentication of this known state so
then the client doesn't have to have
this state in her hands at the beginning
it's just this Republican known
description but can we somehow find a
way to force the prover to prepare
but you say so this protocol it computes
on authenticated data gate by gate some
gates require authenticated magic states
in particular these three gates so this
face gate that we just saw the hannam
are and also the non Clifford T gate and
there's non Clifford T gate even it
requires some interaction between the
client and the server
so this like if you look at the actual
resources that you're using is not a
very good protocol right the client is
still doing all of the work they're kind
of updating key they have to provide all
these authenticated magic states for
most of the gates that we're doing and
even have to interact you can get rid of
this interaction between the client and
the server somehow get to a sort of
verifiable homomorphic encryption but it
still requires a lot from the client
all this contradict computation of the
client does can it be pre-processed you
know yes so so that's yeah very good
questions it is actually what we do in a
verifiable homomorphic encryption paper
essentially the client before had
prepares a whole bunch of these like
authenticated magic states and this
interaction is taken out by some other
gadgets so that the client can do some
of that processing also or the server
can with a classical morph encryption
scheme do some of this processing can
just decode results yeah so you get sort
of it's independent of the actual
computation but it's still of course a
lot of work this is the t gates magic
state protocol and the reason that i do
require some interaction is that this
correction here is not a nice
okay any questions about this sort of
general idea so at some point you said
that the attacker shouldn't know which
which wins our data and vision if now
your client supplies much information
doesn't that get give information to the
attacker yeah except they abuse this
information said of doing some
computation with it
now I know where the data is what the
the error correction is yes sir the
information that's supplied to the to
the server by the client it's never I
mean it depends on the key because it's
also against with encoding but what we
should take care of for example in the
trap code is to use fresh one time pad
key so the information is the key
updates that the client does those are
really kept private to the clients
I hope part of this talk I want to give
you another application that's part of
some recent work multi-party quantum
computation I could talk for entire hour
about this so I will just give you a few
sort of sprinklings of what's going on
I'm not gonna try to give you a full
protocol but in multi-party computation
we have a situation where we have
multiple parties in this case I just
threw two that each have their own
inputs so it's not this asymmetric
client-server setting anymore but it's
really everybody has inputs and
everybody could in principle encode
their inputs to maybe sort of do some
computation together and they want to
check that the other players are
behaving as they should so if you want
to use some of these like verification
properties of Earth indications but this
now a question arises because what
happens if they do some computation
together with these encoding x' where
the first player doesn't know the second
key and the second player doesn't know
the first key and how do they even like
how do they even update keys who can
check whatever comes out and whatnot so
this really gives rise to a whole new
challenge and there's two proposed
solutions for this each have their pros
and cons the first solution is just to
kind of stack authentications or in the
original paper this was called swaddling
so I'm sort of wrapping the states into
many layers of communication and in this
in this solution what what the players
do is whatever everybody else indicates
their own state but then they give it to
all the other players and they just kind
of put layers of authentications on top
but just two players it looks still kind
of feasible if you have many players
this is going to look horrible and as
you can see of course these orders of
authentications are also not the same
thing the nice thing about this solution
is that it really has a kind of
plug-and-play security so we have our
security properties of our
authentication scheme so you can kind of
just use them here directly because
we're just using them
but things become a little bit harder so
support look for example at this one on
the left if player two that was holding
like the key K two wants to check this
authentication everything is fine we can
just do this but if player one during
the computation wants to check whether
everything is still fine with our input
like there's this other authentication
on top so they have to do all kinds of
classical communication there and make
sure that no information about their
cases there's some extra work to be done
there and of course the thing that I
already mentioned if you have more
players to cipher text longer and
there's also some in feasibility if you
wanted to do that but the principle idea
works that we just have everybody do
their own encoding have their own traps
and responsible for their another
another solution that was proposed
little bit more recently is to do a kind
of public authentication test and the
idea here is that well there's just one
encoding on each state usually the other
player will also have some input but
let's just focus on the input if the
left player here so there's just one
encoding on top of the state so that's
nice and simple again you can think of
this for example with the clifford code
so the clifford code is zeros clifford's
but the players they kind of secret
share the key to this encoding so maybe
this random clifford C is actually a
product of two two other random
Clifford's and player one knows the
first one player two notes the other one
you can show because of the group
structure of the Clifford group that if
you know C one then you don't know
anything about C because you need C 2 as
well to get this
and the really cool thing about this
public authentication test or thing we
wanted to achieve with this public
authentication test is that we can have
one player doing kind of all the hard
work so all the quantum work all the
testing and all the other players just
with classical communication with that
single player can verify that the player
actually did this this really comes in a
lot into the idea of this verified
approver stuff again and how it works
well very briefly show you the decoding
player so suppose that this player is
going to to decode and sort of work not
even really decode but just kind of show
that everything is still fine
maybe it's halfway through the
computation they want to show everything
is doing right what they do is they
append another bunch of zeros so we have
these psy tensor 0 with the clifford on
top and then he just outside here puts
another and then together with some
classical communication the players
settle on this clifford here what this
clifford does is well first it undoes
the encoding on the first like on the on
the actual interesting state and then it
applies a random linear function g life
is random g which is a linear
transformation of both these traps that
were already inside the encoding and
these extra zeros that the decoding and
the really nice property about this
function g is that if everything is a
zero then it does nothing then it stays
there but as soon as this combination of
two n strings is not zero then it will
map it to a random bit string non zero
bit string right so even if just one
trap is off then after that all the
traps will be kind of
then they apply a new random fresh
random key again on the on the actual
state and some random bit flips on this
extra just to kind of hide and then they
ask the decoding player to measure this
last bit here or this last n qubits here
and report the value R and I'm brushing
over a lot of details here so what I'm
presenting here is actually not fully
secure because you have to do a lot of
work to make sure that if the decoding
player learns this Clifford that they
don't learn any information about G or C
or C Prime and then the version that I
present here there's actually some
information revealed so you have to do
some extra work but the idea is that all
of this work can be done by the decoding
player except for deciding this Clifford
which is some classical communication
involved and then the decoding player if
he acts honestly he can just measure
this less and qubits and review R and if
he did anything dishonestly then this G
is going to make sure that everything is
mumbled up and he cannot do anything
better than guess are you can never
recover
so other players then they can like
reveal some information so that
everybody knows it's supposed to be and
they can really check that this player
is shared in the first place like this
is like the same part at state and each
of them does see one on there yeah so a
lot of the underlying machinery in our
multi-party computation protocol is any
classical multi-party computation so we
require as a sort of ingredient to our
scheme we require a classical
multi-party computation that really
takes care of a lot of the this type of
work like how do they share keys how do
they even like sample a random are
together without anybody but there is
also some sending of states send sending
states around involved especially
so just to kind of summarize the idea so
all the players inputs are encoded we
saw two options for this multi-part
accommodation either we can stack the
encoding which gives us nice simple
security but big cipher texts or we can
do it kind of shared encoding with the
public and then we can do computations
on this with a kind of gate by gate
computation that's very similar to the
ideas that I showed you in the first
scenario and underlying legal to
Andrea's question underlying me there's
always classical control going on -
there's always this classical leash we
implement by using some classical so
this is also in our scheme where the
computational assumptions coming
so some open problems just to I would
really like to see some more
applications of this public
authentication system I think is it sort
of even outside of the multi-party
computation protocol the idea that we
can force someone to show that
everything is still fine without fully
decoding the state it's really powerful
I'm also interested to see some
applications of multi-party computation
once a multi-party computation so
classically we already know that it has
several locations and which of these
hold through in the quantum world and
how do they compare to maybe some
solutions that we already have to zero
knowledge better with them well one of
my favorite problems because I've been
working on it like a go race is the
beginning of my PhD is the obfuscation
of quantum circuits the reason that I
think this is related to all of these
sort of verification problems is that to
office well to obfuscate a quantum
circuit means to give a user access to
some functionality that they can only
like they can use the function they put
inputs in it and get outfits out but not
really learn anything about the function
itself and the reason that I think it's
related to verification is that
essentially you need to verify that the
user used this box in the correct way
and only then give them the answer to
their computation if they did try to do
anything else with this box like trying
to find out information about the
function that's inside then they
shouldn't get I think sort of the
techniques that we use we're using in
verification protocol I would already
have lying around could be very useful
for this
and this one is maybe more if there's
still any lattice people around or some
post quantum crypto people around in our
multi-party computation paper we use as
a primitive like I mentioned already a
classical multi-party computation scheme
but as far as we could tell there was
not really an established post quantum
secure classical multi-party computation
scheme around that has sort of all the
properties that we needed from it but I
don't think there were any fundamental
issues with that but it seems to be
quite straightforward but you just
somebody has to sit down and make sure
that everything fits together nicely so
quickly some takeaways from this talk so
we sell quantum authentication codes
they guarantee that the quantum state
can remain unaltered and the dependence
it's gone
we saw the flippered code in the trap
code is two examples of such codes but
there are many more examples and these
authentication codes can be used as a
tool for a client-server setting like
verifying that the server did the right
computation they can be used as a tool
for multi-party computation verifying
that the other players did the right
computation but there are some
difficulties with that we need a way to
combine the encoding from different
players and I strongly believe that
there may be many more applications for
this
I want to try an assertion on you and
see what you think given your deep
experience in this area
I want to assert that for every
fault-tolerant quantum computation
protocol that probably exists a
corresponding clock time identification
protocol and and computation protocol of
the nature you've described and vice
versa okay well I certainly agree with
you that there seem to be a lot of
techniques that kind of transfer over
and what not one of the open problems
that I listed but I thought about
including it it it seems that in this
authentication field there's lots of
like specific codes and we kind of keep
reinventing the wheel so we have the
cover code and then we figure out okay
how do we do computations on the
Clifford code and then we have the trap
code and we have to figure out how to do
computations on the trap code so it
would be really nice to sort of have a
unifying framework may be sort of more
abstract representations of these types
of codes and see sort of what patterns
do they follow and how can we do
computation for that and there might be
a link with this fall to around
competitions as well but if there are
recently so many new fault tolerant
computation techniques using peaceable
for tolerance using meshing lattice
close with triangle surgery and each one
of those differs from the measurement
based quantum computation and the
stabilizer coset are now being
traditionally used here for example they
use multiple codes they used to be
miracle with the transversal pi over
eight and so forth and I haven't seen
those migrated into your field I have to
admit that I'm not super familiar with
those sort of most recent development
there so maybe that's a missed
opportunity and I should read up on that
because I yeah I agree there might be
some
complicated it's a complicated question
but so we know classically that this
sort of strongest definition of black
box obfuscation is not possible right
but it's not necessarily the case that
if we use quantum techniques that black
box obfuscation of classical circuits is
might still be possible and you're
willing to make any computational
assumption as long as it's not right yes
at this point yes so for our multi-party
computation protocol the well there's of
course there's quantum communication and
classroom education we didn't analyze
the classical communication so closely
because we figured the quantum
communication would be the bottleneck
and there I recall correctly the number
of rounds of computation is in the order
of the number of players times the
number of
okay depends on the do like you have to
do if you do see notes or not so there
are variants on that it you can help it
differently but roughly the order the
order of magnitude will be so for every
for every like round of Clifford T you
would do need to do one round of
communication and passed the stage
around expensive yes/no for improvement